chat, and you're welcome to another Zoom call. We have a number of questions to get through.
Just to remind you again, please ask your questions on the member site,
and a reminder that you guys all have the ability to get on any of our courses.
I'm just using your same username and password as you do for the member site.
The one that I think would be most helpful is maybe to read your team's course if you really want to
dig into your genetics, and this haven't phased in detoxification. It can mean interesting,
I think, for you most of you know everything and the stuff, but the cancer course certainly
don't need the lab course. Okay, here's a question. This might have been from last week,
but what are your thoughts on the sensor test or scan? Those are electro-dermal screening tests.
There's multiple devices out there for electro-dermal screening. It measures frequency,
is there benefit? Sure, I think there's benefit to that. Do you diagnose off of that? No.
So you can do one of those electro-dermal screening test sensor, or there's a bunch of different names
of them out there, depending on the device themselves, and it comes up, you know,
mold and parasites on this and that and that. Does that mean you have that? No, it doesn't mean you
have that. It means that that frequency came up, and then there's a treatment modality to it that you
use that frequency on a bunch of different acupuncture points, and it can be really helpful,
but you have to be careful if the practitioner crosses the line and says this frequency came up,
therefore you have this disease. There's zero correlative evidence of that, so that's where I think
there's danger in crossing that line and there's danger in, that's I think sometimes these kind of
things are what give alternative practitioners bad names because they are diagnosing off of
things that you shouldn't diagnose. And I don't think that's appropriate. There's no evidence
that that's true. The companies will tell you you don't diagnose off of it, but practitioners tend
to carry that next, carry it into that next step, which is very dangerous. I get, you know, members
contacted us say things like, oh, I did this certain electro-dermal screening and it's that I have
these parasites, so now I want to get some nutrition for those parasites. Well, it doesn't mean
you have those parasites, so you can't stretch that just because the frequency came up positive,
doesn't mean you have the disease, so that is really far-fetched and incorrect, and improper,
and possibly malpractice. It's just wrong to do to stretch that. Can you please speak more on the
topic of spike proteins, evidence how they're passed from backs to unbacks? I'm not going to read the
rest of this question, because it's, I really can't speak much on that. Go to this, this is our
sister website, it's called My Hope for Lime, and on the My Hope for Lime, it's My Hope for Lime.com.
You can look at the blogs and I have written multiple blogs on spike proteins. I have not done a
whole lot of research on spike proteins for quite some time since the vaccine came out, but personally,
I'm very much against the vaccine, I'm very much against, you know, even though you are vaccinated,
you're still exposed to spike proteins, it's causing, there's no one that could possibly give you a
valid argument that it's not increasing the prevalence of different cancers, putting a bunch of
people that have had a diagnosis of cancer on a more rapid track of the testesis. There's a lot
of evidence that shows that that is being buried. You're going to have to search different websites
and different information, and on that blog post, I have some data wherever I pull the information
on spike proteins, all that may damage your DNA, how it increases your cancer risk, it increases
if you already have a diagnosis of cancer. So go on the My Hope for Lime.com, go to the blog that I
have multiple blog posts on that. If you have any thoughts on true rice, new jackhammer,
amplification system, this is another question we had just last week or two weeks before. Again, the jack
hammer increases the output of the bulb, so you can use it with the hammer bulb. They're not very
expensive. To me, the only real benefit of that is if you're using it during the day and you're up
and you're moving around and the bulb is away from you and you're not able to have the bulb right
next to you. So if you're having the bulb right next to you with the hammer bulb,
again, any increase in power is wasted because it's powerful enough by itself to go
for those frequencies to go through you. You don't need them to go through the adjacent wall and
into the next through. So if you're the use of the jackhammer, I think comes in with while I'm
running them during the day and I have the bulb sitting on my desk because I get up and
off by desk to do different things. Well, that's where the jackhammer would be more appropriate.
But able to have the bulb right next to you, then I don't think it's necessary.
In order to fight back, what basis in law forces your clinic to remove and bend is all products
for your site? Because I mentioned last week that we had to remove all the bent is all products
from our site. Now, we can still sell them, but we can't have them on our site and we can't have
any data on our website regarding them. And the rule of law is the FDA. So the Wooddrug
Administration controls the use of supplements and off-label drugs. And then is all is a drug,
but it's not a human drug. So there was a gray area. We were using it for cancer,
on humans. And since it's not a human drug, the source that we were using, we were in kind of a
gray area of being able to actually sell it on our site. I knew that I knew what was going to happen
because since COVID, they have been given a lot more power. The CDC, all the three-letter named
governmental control agencies have been given much more power. And they've been able to come after
places like us in different ways. Now, I do believe that we're protected, but we do have to play
by their rules. I can't fight that and say, no, we're not going to agree with your stipulation.
The FDA will just find you. There's no court of law. I mean, I could get an attorney and try to
sue them back. There's no way you're going to win. So on something like that, it's just not worth
a bite. So for those of you that are unfind as all, we just call the clinic and order from us directly
will put it in your next order. The protection that we have from the pastoral medical society does not
override the ability to go against an FDA order. The truth is that you could Google, I just did
this last week, Ben Ben is all in cancer, and you can't find anything anymore. So they literally came
against every clinic that was selling Ben Ben is all and you can't even find Joe Timmons
information. He still has a website up, but you have to go directly to his website, the shadow man
his website. So you can't find him on Google, Google buried him. Is that legal? Is that ethical?
Of course not. Is it moral? Absolutely not. But Google hides under their stipulation that they're
a private entity and they could do whatever they want. So, you know, it's insane. So I remember
I used to see an MD who embraced alternative practices who led his license lab and made me
sign a waiver each time we met. Can that no longer be done? Well, yes. So we're still, you know,
I don't have any fear that we're going to be out of business. We're going to still do what we're
doing. We just have to take precautions to protect ourselves. And one of the things is, first of all,
first of all, let's take a step back. The FDA governs the rule, the sale of supplements and
everything. And I know a lot, you know, I've toured a lot of the supplement companies that we sell
supplements to or sell their supplements. And I've toured their facilities and stuff. And they,
you know, talk to the managers and the owners of those companies. And they say, all the time,
they get, at least every three to six months, they get letters from the FDA and inspections
from the FDA and surprise inspections from the FDA and all that kind of stuff. And you just have
to deal with it, you know, it's just part of doing business. It's just dealing with the government.
Then they just make the changes that they have to make, you know, and, you know, they are able to
avoid the fines. And it's just part of doing business. And so it's nothing that concerns me or worries
me, but it's just sans me. It's just really, it's sorrowful because it's like the government has to put
their big foot in everything, which they are in bed with the pharmaceutical industry. So anything
that's going to impede against what the pharmaceutical industry is doing, well, they're going to try to
shut it down. I mean, it's just no different than what happened in the 1950s, where they shut down
hoxy and they shut down gurson. And these people literally had their, the chains on their clinic
literally, they came to work in the morning. And hoxy and there was chains on the outside door of his
clinic. Rife, his, all his stuff was confiscated and taken. How do you fight back against the government?
I mean, yeah, you can file a lawsuit and you might win, but it will be 10 years later, you know, after
they appeal it 10 times, that you're just wiped out. You just financially wiped out. So you just try
to do what you can, know that God's going to protect you, but I am complete faith that he's going to
protect us. But it's like, okay, we can't have fed vendors on our site. We can't have anything about
Joe Tipens or Fernandez on our blog post anymore. So much for the freedom of speech.
But they have lit. Otherwise, we're just going to get completely shadowed by Google and you
won't be able to invite their clinic. So it's very sad. It is really sad. I like to contact my
senators and congressmen on this topic to of whom I know personally and help get elected, which will
hopefully make a little bit of a difference. Maybe and I appreciate that. I really, really do.
These draconian practices by government are basically such that they threaten my life and others
that I just I just won't stand for it. Well, I am full agreement, but I don't think, you know,
your local senators or congressmen really, you know, the less you had a majority that were against
this. They're not going to do anything. And their pockets are lying. You know, I actually treated
once a person who was a congress, US congress person. And this person was telling me that they had
to raise $4 billion by next week. And this person was very stressed out and I'll never forget talking
to that person and saying, you have to, what do you really have to raise $4 million? Oh, yeah,
the party that this person was represented by said I have to raise $4 million by Tuesday.
And it's like, okay, if you have to raise that kind of money, that kind of that speed, you start
taking it from pretty much anybody and who has the money, the pharmaceutical companies. These
people are bought and paid for. No matter how honest and ethical, it may be a little cynical. But,
you know, no matter how honest and ethical they are, there's the pharmaceutical companies help
them get elected. And, you know, you invite as easily persuaded to justify maybe poor ethics.
And you'd say, well, the pharmaceutical companies, yeah, they're bad and they're in control,
they squash the alternatives. But, you know, look at all the good they do. Look at all the people
they employ. Look at all the Americans that are at work because of them. And, you know, it's easy to
justify, you know, evil when you're kind of, when they're the ones greaser that we all, it's really,
it's really difficult to fight back against this thing. I appreciate it. I appreciate all you're
good. Please don't use my name. I know you would, you wouldn't. This person wouldn't. But, you know,
it's just, you know, the evil that's out there more power to destroy us even more.
I don't worry about us. We're not going to be, you know, out of business or anything like that.
We just have to follow their guidelines. And, you know, it's just as what it is. Again, I'm
just sad. It's a saddens me, you know, that all through this whole Coleman thing, you couldn't
even talk about, you know, alternative things or you would get, you would get bad, you'd get,
we've had videos pulled off of YouTube. We've had, and we haven't gotten into the Coleman thing.
That's why we had to put this article on, COVID on a sister site because I didn't want our
Connor's clinic site to get completely shadowed. So, yeah, it's just a sad state of affairs that we're
in right now. This Coleman Cancer study got a lot of publicity a few months back. It's about the PD-1
blockade in Miss Batch repair. The study started with anti PD-PD-1 medical antibody, which was
administered every three to six, three weeks or six months for patients with Miss Batch, paired
efficient stage two or stage three rectal antelcarcinoma. It was so successful that chemotherapy and
resection was unnecessary for all 14 patients in the study. Well, there you have it right there.
It was successful that chemotherapy was unnecessary. It's going to be a study that probably isn't going
to be read by a lot of people because it's not going to become standards of care because
chemotherapy makes money. So, gosh, that sounds so cynical, but it just isn't true. So for those who
are familiar with what idea this is talking about, this is where, this is really a study about
immunotherapy. So, the PD-1 receptor is on T cells. So, your T cells are what are your main killer
cells of cancer. But the cancer, again, remember, I said this a hundred times. One of the reasons why
your immune system isn't killing cancer is because cancer is your own cells. And your own cells
have this connection to the PD-1 receptor that basically blocks a T cell from killing it
because if, you know, because all your own cells have this. So, it keeps you from developing auto
immune diseases. It keeps your immune system from just killing yourself tissue. Otherwise,
if you didn't have that, your immune system would just kill you and you would have been dead at two
weeks of age and never lived to adulthood because your immune system would have killed you.
But, the goodness your body has these protective measures to protect
your immune system from killing self tissue. And one of those protective measures is the PD-1
receptor on activated T cells. Now, some, now there's a test that is done. So, that's where
immunotherapy. So, immunotherapy is not chemotherapy. Immunotherapy is another drug. So, one of the
brand-aids is K-truda. So, let's talk about K-truda. That's a drug that has an anti-PD-1 receptor
device that's what the drug does. It blocks the PD-1 receptor. So, activated T cells, your immune
cells will kill the tumor cells. Well, that sounds like a great idea. Well, it is a great idea.
The problem is, is that you can't have secondary negative effects of it because it doesn't just kill
the tumor. Your activated T cells, it starts killing self tissue everywhere. You start developing
autoimmune diseases elsewhere in the body. Now, some people can tolerate that just fine. And
the immunotherapy works really well. Some people don't tolerate the immunotherapy just fine,
and they can end up with anything that ends with anitis. So, colitis, you'll get this inflammatory
colon and diarrhea, bloody stools, and all this. Now, where you get, you know, if you already
have an autoimmune disease, it can make it much worse. So, some people do not tolerate
immunotherapy well. Some people, hey, they can deal with those symptoms and you can take different
nutrition and even medication for those other symptoms. If it affects the immunotherapy is
stimulating your activated T cells to kill tumor cells and you're getting regression of the tumor
well, then there's a trade-off there and there's a benefit to that. Now, there's a test that's done
to see if your cancer is really, you know, that's a major problem with your cancer is that your
activated T cells are being turned off by your tumor cells through that PD1 receptor.
That's what's called the PD1 blockade. Now, if that's not true, if you don't test for that,
then they won't administer immunotherapy to you. They'll say it won't work for you. Now, the question
that is being asked here is they actually, in one of the studies, they actually did
they administered still immunotherapy to these people that did not show that high PD1 blockade
and it still had some effect and this person is the question this person is asking. We had another
doctor pointed out that Dr. Moss said that this assumption is not correct and it may be appropriate
for people who are not genetically eligible, meeting that if that doesn't even show in you, again,
they won't give you the drug, but actually if they still gave you the drug, it might actually
still help you. So, and I would agree with that, you know, but they have their stipulations. They
won't administer immunotherapy and these people because you don't show positive in their test and
you might have to just search for and a collegeist that will basically give it to kind of off label.
So, they're probably out there and you can certainly try to do it. Understand it's still
immunotherapy can still have inside effects and such, but I still think it's, I, you know, we've had
patients that have done immunotherapy that have done really poorly with it, but we've had more patients
that have done immunotherapy that didn't really well with it. So, I'm actually still quite a
fan of the immunotherapy. I know that chemo does not kill cancer stem cells or circulated two
of our cells. Do we take supplements to help build the immune system so that they can help this?
That's exactly what you're doing. That's plus you're using the right to help stimulate
the attack of circulated two of their cells. And back to this, that's exactly why you're using the
right to at least one reason. If you cause disruption in that tumor cell over and over and over and over
and over again because you're hitting it with frequencies that can override, in my opinion, that PD1
receptor issue. That's why you would use the right one of the reasons why you use the right because it
can help still stimulate attack to the tumor to the cancer site of your immune system because you're
causing your immune system to take another look at another look at another look at this and it could
override that turn off receptor and PD1 receptor unactivated T cells. My chemoglobin tested today at 7.9
and I'm scheduled for surgery in three weeks. They went through my chemoglobin either up with
either a blood transfusion or supplementation. I don't cancer cells feed on iron. What would we
recommend in this situation? I'd recommend a blood transfusion. So there's nothing that's going to
raise your he will go even faster than a transfusion. Supplementation of iron might slowly creep it up.
If you're going to use supplementation of iron, use Artemisidine with the iron, take Artemisidine with
the iron because cancer cells can feed on iron and it tends to drag Artemisidine with it. So if you're
going to take iron, take Artemisidine as well, but nothing will raise your hemoglobin faster than
a transfusion. Is it possible that when taking supplements, it could cause kidney pain? At least
that is where I think it may be. So I'd have painted the back flake. Some seems like some days after I
take them, the pain is more intense than others. I'm just not sure where to start when I do not notice
it every day. Currently I take about 15 different things. I'd highly suggest that you take make sure
you're taking your supplements with your food. I don't want to say supplements couldn't cause kidney
pain. If you just take your supplements and you have that pain, I would say no, absolutely not
because it takes time for those supplements to absorb and then circulates your bloodstream. If there
was something that was irritating your kidneys, it would have to be at least a couple of hours after
you take your supplements that you would notice the kidney pain. If you notice flake pain after you
take your supplements, it could be referred pain from the stomach or the gut, meaning just there's
some irritation maybe on the capsules. Try opening the capsules up if they're not time-released
supplements. Hopefully they're about putting them in a shake or something and taking them that way.
Sometimes the capsules, even though they're natural, capsules can cause irritation to the stomach
and you could get referred pain to the back and might feel like kidney pain, but it's actually
probably just referred pain to the back. Okay, question from the chat. Hi, Dr. Cutters. I'm about to
take the four main off-label medications from care oncology that has been formed. Would these drugs
interfere with my current supplement protocol, such as Burberry, CLI-No? They shouldn't, you know,
none of them should interfere with that. The only one that you're taking the docks is cycling.
From care oncology, I would take that maybe away from any probiotics because it will just kill them.
So maybe take that at least four hours away from the probiotics, but like the
med-formative, such no one should not be in addition to them. I would consider doing another tissue
bioxid andoscopy this time to be able to put my specific type of cancer out there to see if there
could be any specific type of immunotherapy that might work for me. So it's just what we're talking
about today. Does this sound like a smart thing to do? Sure, for sure. I think absolutely if your
cancer is not responding to something you're doing currently, it's always good to look at something
else. If you are responding currently and you're doing well, still a lot of bad idea to at
least have your options open in case something turns for the worst or something, worst case scenario.
So I think it's always wise to be looking at. Can burberry cause lowly?
Well, burberry is the best supplement to kill H. Pylora. H. Pylora is helicobacter Pylora.
That is very common in the gut that can cause all sorts of problems. It can be a cause of stomach
cancer. It can it is the cause of all stomach ulcers and doandal ulcers. It is H. Pylora. I can
disrupt the cause dysbiosis in the gut. It can cause skin rashes. It is sort of the top five
causes cardiovascular disease and the endothelial damage. So H. Pylora is a major player and it's
basically ubiquitous. H. Pylora in balance is a part of our flora, our normal
like robyada, but it gets out of balance very quickly and very easily. So if burberry is causing bloating
my first suggestion is it's quite possible that you have H. Pylora also.
And H. Pylora can be and usually often is completely independent in person's cancer. It's a secondary
morbidity that most people have. And I take burberry on a fairly regular basis because my dad had a
history of heart disease. And again, once the number one cause of endothelial damage and
heart issues is H. Pylora. It's one of the time causes. So I take burberry because it's a great
thing for that. Burberry is also fantastic to help lower blood sugar. So it's really good for
cancer patients. Burberry is, I tell you, burberry honestly is one of my favorite supplements
maybe other than mushrooms. So if you're getting bloating from the burberry, I'd say that probably
is a good thing. Make sure you're taking some fiber. Make sure you're doing coffee animals.
If you're constantly getting bloating after being on burberry for months and months,
they make sure you then just try taking it with some food or something like that.
Again, I don't know if the burberry is causing the bloating, but if it certainly can cause bloating
on some sorts if a person, especially if a person has an H. Pylora. Any other questions?
Should I work up to my three times for that? Yeah. So it's always good to, if a supplement, if you
think that something is causing issues, you, you, you, you on titrate that supplement.
Oh my goodness, this supplement really gives me a stomach ache or something. I'll drop it down
to, to none for a few days and go to one if you're supposed to be taking three a day and do one for
a week or so and then titrate up to two and things like that. And also remember that you, if you're
supposed to be taking three a day based upon the recommendations, you split them up through the day.
So you're not taking three all at once. That looks quite often. I might take three burberry and all
at once, but you might be much more sensitive to anything than I might be. So, but again, if you
recommended that you take three a day of anything, you should try to split those up throughout the day
because all these things have a half life in your system. And they can be gone.
Okay, we will finish for the day. I will see you in two days.
The day before Thanksgiving. I hope you guys all have a great Thanksgiving plan with your families.
There's a lot to be thankful for. So the more we can be thankful and grateful, even in difficult times,
the it just brings us health and it's so good for us. So keep a thankful heart. Keep a grateful heart.
Ask God to reveal in you any bitterness that needs to be dealt with
that he can heal you. So thank you very much. Love you all. Be prayed for you and we'll see you in two days.